warning this episode may contain content
that is not suitable for children viewer
discretion is
advised welcome back to a special LED
that is a necessary LED um we're going
to talk about a subject that you maybe
don't hear very often um there's a lot
of terms uh secret sin uh self abuse
what's the real term masturbation
masturbation
and I think that we need information on
this particular topic because this is
something
that I want to just go out on a limb
here maybe everybody deals with at some
point in time and uh it needs to have
some light shed on it so I got Teemo
Hoffman um Teemo it's a blessing to have
you on our show thank you he's from
Germany lives in the Netherlands and uh
he has a podcast uh YouTube channel that
he's sharing
lots of different messages um his
testimony was
powerful you should click on that
testimony and watch this because it was
a beautiful story of how God led him out
of being a alter boy out of the heavy
metal environment and then and then into
Ministry and so he's got a passion for
um sharing truth with with people and
this is one of the topics that uh we
decided to discuss today so welcome
aboard team thank you so much for having
me and I believe you know this topic
really needs to be addressed because um
I mean people are so exposed to this
today so openly and uh we're living in a
time where just everyone just with one
click you know can I mean immediately
exposed to these things and we will talk
about this so um but in the same time I
wanted to say that for me personally uh
I'm not ashamed to talk about these
things amen without going into like too
much you know images detail but I think
it's important to uh hear a testimony to
see of God's power right uh because if
you have experience and we will hear
that if experien that kind of power God
can can set you free you're not ashamed
of the Gospel so and that's is what I
believe is the solution what we need
that's right and and it's important to
be honest as well I noticed that um when
I came out of Hollywood I was heavily
involved in drugs and I remember the
first time that I was speaking up front
of a church group um there was a lot of
my family members in the audience that
had not ever heard me verbalize what I
was engaging in and and you know I
remember praying about it and I felt
inspired to to shed some light on it and
it was one of those things that helped
me overcome that thing because I was
sharing light on it the devil loves
secrecy and if we don't talk about it
it's a difficult thing to overcome you
come to grips with it and you talk about
it openly um I think that that uh God
can really take that and run with it yes
definitely so you know in my case for
example um I was just exposed to
masturbation when I was around maybe 5
years old wow very young um I cannot
even tell you today what actually
happened so even if you see sometimes
babies if they touch their genitals and
have this happy you know funny feeling
not knowing actually what they're doing
doesn't mean that they immediately start
to to
masturbate um but they're exposed in
that way and I think I mean what I'm now
saying it goes completely against like a
worldly mindset that people say okay but
you know it's a child needs to be
exposed to these things to discover his
his body and things like this but I
think even that parents should be
encouraged to and situations even like
that when it starts in that age to stop
the child from doing that you know I
need I I mean it sounds very
conservative but I believe it's it's
quite helpful because as we will hear my
story so um I was exposed to that I
didn't learn it from somebody or watch
something I don't know how I came up
with this but my earliest remembrance of
that is when I was 5 years old um doing
these things hiding it I mean that's so
young I don't even I don't I mean at 5
years old first grade you know you're
you're you're learning about how to read
in mathematics was still a kindergarten
you know kindergarten yes was not even
in school yet and and and trust me the
internet was not what it is today uh you
know now every kid has some kind of
device in their hands that's connected
to the worldwide web and how can that I
mean they don't they don't say if your
kid is exposed anymore they say when
yeah and generally it's very quick when
your kids start playing with internet
yeah I mean today you know in Germany
there's right now a movement growing
that they teach this even to children
when they are 2 or 3 years old they're
going into
kindergarten I mean it's not everywhere
in Germany but it starts they go into
kindergartens and teach two three year
olds how they can masturbate and if they
don't know how to do this then they
teach them and it's just crazy it's
mindboggling it's really you live in the
Netherlands I remember coming across
some some information about um in public
school systems sometimes to to introduce
the kids to sex education they're having
adults take off their clothes in front
of these 5-year-olds yeah yeah they have
all these these books I mean you have it
here in the US as well but they're in
the Netherlands very strong that they
teach you from books and it's every you
have all these pictures and everything
so it's it's really bad because um when
I started this when I was 5 years old I
really you know first of all I did it in
secret obviously because somehow you
know Jesus says in the word if if you
know um that people do things in secret
because they know it's not right to do
right so why are we not doing it like in
the open in the open you know we know
that's something maybe of course very
private but when it then comes to
nakedness and these things there must be
something that there's a reason why God
in the beginning you know that Adam and
Eve sinned they lost naked they felt
naked and all these things so there must
be reason for this and I think that
everyone um can you know can catch this
idea so um I remember that um I mean I
had pleasure with this obviously because
it's something what has happening in
your brain that is dopamine you know you
have this dopamine
release um and we will talk about this
what is happening actually in your body
later but um so it was a pleasure thing
to do for me and um I don't remember
really if I was thinking about specific
things because I was not exposed to
pornography yet but what I remember is
that my brother and I we had this game
um we sometimes we we uh took these
catalogs from um companies who sell like
clothing or furniture There was a
lingerie section yes oh yes exactly I
remember those as a kid I remember my I
mean today I love about it but it's my
brother and I we went through these
things and we had like these monop money
and we played this game that um we could
buy like for our house that we obviously
didn't have but buy furniture from that
but specifically me I mean my brother
did it I guess maybe a little bit as
well but specifically for me every time
when we came to this section where you
saw these women wearing you know these
lightly clothing I was spending my money
on that you're buying the girl yes so I
wanted you know to I was know
somehow yeah um I was into that and then
later I guess when I was about 10 years
old I mean the internet actually was not
around that time yet it came maybe when
I was 12 13 you that
old I remember I remember first hearing
about the internet and I was I think I
was around that age as well yeah so um
but then I mean friends they came up
with these magazines which were very
popular back then like the Playboy like
this and then we were even more exposed
like to nakedness and um there was a
level of of difficulty to be exposed to
those kind of things there was an
embarrassment of either you had to buy
it from a store or you know get a hold
of it or whatever it it it's sent to
people's phones today I mean these kids
have no context of of of these things at
all and they're slimed with a lot of
images that that is like they don't have
to go looking very hard for it yeah yeah
so again I try to to hide this from my
parents because again you see that it's
something that you know in the back of
your mind you know that's something
wrong with this they want to proove of
this yes yes
exactly um so then the internet came
obviously you know in school public
school we were exposed to this with
friends we exchanged videos things like
this and actually over a time um you
know I filled up my my computer with
that stuff wow I had even specific files
where I had like my favorite videos
favorite artists so to say that I was
watching and
um yeah so it was you you know it's
funny just just to hang on that for a
second you know they call them artists
or actors and and they even say they're
acting because that's the reality they
are really acting they do do not
actually like that and when you see
testimonies of them that are doing that
they have to numb with drugs and with
for the stuff they're acting that that
is pleasurable to them and it's not
absolutely I remember um a person I met
many years ago when I was already out uh
when I came out of these things uh he
mentioned once to me he was a young
young fellow he said to me yeah I had
you know um he was also struggling a
little bit in his walk with God he said
I had my first girlfriend recently and
then we started to have sex and I was
wondering you know she is not reacting
and bad like you know I'm I'm used to
from these movies I said yeah that's
fake you know it's not if you start to
have sex with that person it doesn't
mean that that that that um girl or
woman whatever that she starts to scream
you know and it's just overwhelming
everything like this yeah but this is
what they are exposed to and then they
they receive or we receive that that
kind of picture how sexuality is and and
relationships are yeah so I was very
much into this I must say that once in a
while I I must confess that I did it
even four or five times a day wow so not
every day but there were times where I
did this sometimes even when I was just
bored yeah didn't know what to do right
now you know that then I did it because
you have all the time again you have in
your brain the dopamine is released this
this pleasure comes the situation of of
you feeling good and well and it's
something which which I believe is um
connected a reason for that um that God
says in in his word that sexuality is
part of marriage because today I see it
something like that God is asking us to
wait uh first of all that um when you
see the Life of Christ he was always
serving people who was never thinking
about himself MH I mean we talk about
self abuse right so why self abuse yeah
what's what's why do they call it abuse
what are you actually abusing yeah so
actually um first of all you break the
rule the golden rule that you should
love your neighbor as yourself M so when
God has given sexuality in the frame of
marriage then I see it as something
first of all of course to serve the
other person but it's also something
that protects you in marriage Paul says
you shouldn't be also too long to be
separated I see it like a super glue
that you're using um so if you have sex
with your spouse um because it also of
course it's it's pleasureful I believe
also that God has given sexuality as
something that should be pleasureful
don't believe in the concept that's just
you know to reproduce I don't believe
that um but it has a specific frame
where protects us that the other person
is not hurt and that you serve the other
person and not yourself mhm but this is
you know it goes along with self abuse
because you always just thinking upon
yourself having that pleasure four or
five times even a day MH um not knowing
also we talk about is what it does to
your body MH you know when it comes to
phys physical and mental health mhm so
um but if you use that so quote unquote
superglue sexuality in the marriage it
keeps you together I experienced in my
life I had several relationships before
I met my wife um and every time when we
broke up it was just amazingly
hurtful why that because you know it's
like you used something MH um and I
believe it's not even SE sexuality it's
also when you come too close even
sometimes with things that you maybe
maybe should even wait you know before
my wife and I for example we waited even
with our first kiss until the um wedding
day wow beautiful yeah so because that's
a rarity yeah because we believed in the
concept now we understood as Christians
then later that when we come too close
with each other even that can hurt you
because you build up on a relationship
or on a
foundation um which if you break up the
relationship for whatever reason it will
hurt you so it's like this you know if
you you use use super glue for something
to put together right so if you te tear
it apart yeah it's it's it tears apart
some of the parts of each side yes it
it's interesting to me that God designed
this thing to bring us close I love the
idea that it's supposed to be this one
person if you just think about this even
even in the masturbation realm right
you're thinking of somebody else but
that that that somebody else could be
somebody's wife yes I mean you think of
like like you're coting someone else's
wife that's not your wife and there's a
lot of of um damage that goes on inside
of you because you're now like basically
taking pleasure you're pleasing yourself
and it's breaking that model of what
real love is others Focus God so loved
the world that he gave his only begotten
son it's giving right lust is taking
that's why we always make movies with
like vampires and they want to suck your
blood and they call that love right no
that's not love that's lust you're
wanting to take someone's life so that
you get pleasure off of it and so I
think it begins to break down this model
and what's even more fascinating is how
can you do the same activity in a
marriage concept and it can be a
blessing to you you can literally do
that same thing outside of a marriage
concept and it can be damaging to you
the ACT is the same basically yeah yeah
there's definitely a reason that God has
said here's there's a frame which will
keep you joyful and I mean you know if
you have sex with your spouse and you
have the attitude to to serve that other
person then the Bible says you know the
person who gives will be actually at the
end will be more blessed yeah because
you serving one another and again it
protects you so focusing on yourself is
something that always destroys you
always and understanding today that our
walk with God is a walk not just to
believe okay there's God maybe creat in
heaven it's really that personal
relationship is all about that God wants
to change our character amen so and if I
partic participate in something that is
focused on me and not on others I always
you know just serving My Flesh the L of
the flesh Galatians 5 and never you know
that God cannot produce the fruit of the
spirit in me becoming selfless how
Christ is and then seeing that in
serving is actually the greatest joy
it's almost like you you can easily tell
it's right or wrong right is this for me
or is this like benefiting you know
somebody else or am I doing this for for
selfish reasons yeah it's actually very
easy and if you think about the health
part for example you know when we have
always these dopamine
um how do you say this like this
dopamine um rush rush in your brain
thank you then it actually the the more
you do it it will change into adrenaline
so and this is very damaging for your
body it's it's quite interesting people
don't know that and um there was even a
movement in the 1900s where people
Educators that were talking about this
that that you can become even mentally
ill of that wow you can um even their
reports of people um I mean it sounds
quite crazy when I say this but like
even blindness and things like this
which were linked yeah to masturbation
wow there's so many things going on in
your body which can really hurt and and
I understand somebody might say but you
know if you have sex with your spouse so
isn't that the same you have an you know
ejulation as a as a man and an orgasms
and these things but the point is
there's a principle in the Bible and
this principle is
temperance and this is very important I
mean of course you know it's actually
the result of it it's um if you come to
or orgasm the result is the same at the
end um but even in Mar marage if you
overdo yeah you know at all the time I
don't believe that this is in in in
harmony with God's will because again
it's selfish you know if you're always
seeking for that you're bringing up an
interesting point because even in a
marriage concept it's not necessarily
just that oh I'm married now I can do
what I want to please me right even in a
marriage you can actually use your wife
as a tool to get you whatever you want
and and that's not that's not others
focused you know and many many
relationships will will really strain at
that point where God designed this thing
to bring us closer together and to
appreciate the other person to to want
to be nice I mean I think the reason why
he made us different than than the
opposite gender as well is because there
are things that the woman wants out of
the relationship that I like the I like
the saying of like like hey look as a as
a married man and you want your wife to
do this activity more you got to be nice
to your wife you know and and it's a
two-way street and it and I think it
really helps us see this is really what
God is about and he gave us this
beautiful gift to demonstrate on a
physical level uh what love is yeah
definitely and U you know many people
think okay as soon as I get married then
you know it's over then will stop and
things like this classic drug addiction
and I believe even many Christians think
that way okay and then they rush into
marriage and they make might make a
wrong decision uh concerning the person
that they will marry um I mean God can
still work out things definitely he's
he's patient and graceful but you can
find up yourself in a situation that you
become very desperate because you're not
receiving what you think is right that
you should receive and um the wife can
be you know very even like disappointed
that she might not serve so to say the
husband in the way how he expects it
that can cause a lot of strife
especially if the husband's been paying
attention to a lot of unrealistic
pictures most women aren't going to ever
try that or do that and so you build up
this this thing that excites you but yet
that's not reality yeah um I've also
heard it explained like um we as males
were very visual I think that's why you
know the the female body is very like
attractive to us and and um
you're taking a picture inside of your
brain what is what is something that
gives you an arousal right that picture
is supposed to be your wife and this
particular woman when you think of this
particular woman that starts getting
your your heart beating and your
emotions going right and and when you
have pictures of varieties of women what
happens if you lay picture on picture on
picture it becomes a fuzzy picture so
the self abuse part is really what
you're doing is you're messing with that
that mechanics of saying this is what
will arouse you this woman in this shape
but now it's just this blurred image
because it's just got too many images on
it yeah you destroy yourself definitely
I mean I um God is merciful and I will
share in a minute how God you know took
me out of this but it's still a Str
struggle in that sense of to um when you
become a Christian and see you know to
to get rid of these things
you really need to die to self amen you
know it's it's it's so to say hard work
with God's grace but there's a effort um
because it's so strong I mean and I just
wanted to mention this as well it's not
actually just only a man thing anymore
you know it's so strong even when it
comes to females I remember when I
started to talk about these things in
public um there were quite a lot of
females approaching me telling me you
know I'm thanking you for sharing this
and uh you know I have to struggle with
I'm struggling with that as well so I
don't go too much into detail with them
then I you know ask them please to talk
with my wife about these things I don't
want to hear much there's an appropriate
level of how to deal with this you also
mentioned something about an elderly
person yeah exactly I remember once on a
camp meeting uh I gave him my testimony
about that and uh there was a guy a
church member actually over 80 he came
he was really crying and he said said
you know I'm so thankful never heard
about somebody openly talking about his
his testimony in that area and how he
overcame and I must tell you you know
that yeah I'm now over 80 but I'm still
struggling with that I don't know how to
get rid of this but today I heard your
testimony and he was very encouraged he
was in tears and he embraced me and he
said you know I'm so thankful that God
gave you the the courage to to to stand
up and share this 80 years plus yeah and
still it's a lifelong struggle this is
why I I remember being early when I was
exposed to some of these things and so
that began a journey way back then right
and it's it's it's a struggle throughout
your life if you cannot overcome it
right yeah that's why we need to talk
about these things that's why we need to
share you know Victory stories and that
God actually can can resolve you of this
if you're willing to surrender and
submit to him but um yeah this is no
longer just a a teenage or college age
range problem this married couples deal
with this and we've talked with lots of
people over the times that we've brought
up some of these conversations and and
so um you know first I believe it's
prayer you know you got to really just
just lay it before God and and then he
ask him to open up the door to you being
able to um walk through those steps yeah
so when I became a Christian
um and um became acquainted with the
Bible and said you know I want really to
set my life on that road to follow God
um first of all it was interesting I
never read something about that
pornography could be bad or a church was
not CH a church member who approached me
I just got the strong impression from
the holy spirit that these things are
not right to have pornography on your
laptop and watching these things MH and
then of course masturbate because I've
even heard people they say yeah but as
long as I don't have pornography on my
laptop I can still masturbate and I tell
you you know that's not yeah but you
know what they do have pornography on
the on the hard drive it's on the hard
drive yeah yeah it is there mhm and um
so but anyway
I um I said to God okay um I must tell
you it was not easy actually that day
when I realized that uh was early in my
my Christian experience after my
conversion that um I went to my laptop
and I just decided okay Lord I just
deleted immed Ely and I think this is um
important principle when the Bible tells
you like in Hebrews 4 I think it's verse
6 uh where it says that today when we
hear God's voice you know we should not
Harden our hearts but listen to what the
Holy Spirit tells us so I immediately
went there I deleted everything and
again was not easy but it was like the
first step for me to um come on on the
path of healing
so after that I um had still struggles
with that because you just said it's
still here in your brain you cannot just
delete it immediately and you know doing
this for over now let me
think decades yeah decades over 20 years
doing that you know every day uh it's
very strong on you and um of course
first you think some is taking away from
me because it brings so much pleasure or
enjoy but I understood it uh you know
all these Concepts that we now talk
about and um so I prayed I was sincere I
said to God lord I want to get get rid
of this but I don't know how and then
like kind of I I was praying I tried
also like as much as possible to avoid
those things I can say from that very
moment actually when I deleted
everything on my laptop and never never
until this very day went once back to
one of those web pages or videos or
whatever it was really God's grace but
again I had still this this struggle and
um
so I remember in the beginning I quit
doing it for 10
days so and uh I was really this was for
me huge you know really huge and then I
remember I don't know was in a situation
and it's the urge was so strong so I
fall into that I felt very bad and
ashamed and of course in that situation
Satan is coming and is is really hard on
you but I remember the promise that
specifically in that situation that we
should come to Christ because there's no
help without um outside of Christ the
Bible says that there is no temptation
that that God has allowed us to
experience that he hasn't given us a way
out yeah and when you recognize how God
works you listen to that still Small
Voice it is amazing when you're
presented with the choice of doing
something that's right or wrong you if
you pay attention to the right things
that happen your phone will ring someone
will you thought you maybe you see a
picture of your wife on and you on the
wall or something that gives you the
opportunity to say oh yeah yeah yeah no
no no I want to I want to go this way or
that way and there's there's you know a
little thought that floats through your
mind you shouldn't be doing this you
know you have to learn to strengthen
those definitely so I started to
understand the the concept of I compare
it let's say you have two piles of
stones mhm and every time when like
talking about it's a habit you know to
do this so and like with every Habit in
life um there can be bad habits it can
be good habits so I understood I got
this picture in my mind was thinking
okay I have over 20 years now I'm doing
this every day on this side there's a
big pile of stones presenting you know
every time when I did this so I was
thinking and I read about this um this
principle in a very amazing uh some very
amazing Christian books or I I read
about this uh where she's explaining so
every time when we take hold of God's
hand and stay faithful that we take like
one of those stones and put it on the
other side nice so and it's really
literally in your brain you know your
neuros cells um or new connection starts
in your brain for good habit mhm but of
course even if you reject in a situation
you stay faithful that pile of stones is
still you know huge and strong on you
and this is what was in my life so I I
quit doing it maybe for a few months and
then I was really happy and I fall back
again felt ashamed once in a while I was
even tempted to do it and I said to Lord
to the Lord yeah I know I don't know how
to get out of this right now even I'm
praying I don't know it doesn't really
it seemed to be not helping in that
situation you know but um I could quit
for longer times and I saw that I got
step by step stronger but at the same
time I needed to be careful not to be
exposed on like I mean you just need to
drive through the city then you have all
these advertisements right there's
triggers yeah and you have to learn to
recognize the triggers yeah the Bible
says we should flee the devil so there's
a co-working co- partnership with God of
course it's it's on God's side finally
that he gives us the strength and power
to overcome but there's a co-partnership
with him that we we cannot expect that
God helps us if we
know you don't wonder he's not dragging
you and forcing you and it's a voluntary
thing but he will step through it with
with you as a gentleman he will pick you
up and help you but you need to be you
know responding with him M so I was in
that situation I didn't do it for quite
a few while few months and then this
strong urge Came Upon me I was on a walk
I remember then the wiards where I lived
and um just out of the blue I was not
thinking about something sexual but then
it came like a strong urge upon me to do
it h a windmill yeah I don't know so um
I made my way home and I was in between
I was praying I said Lord I don't want
to do this but this was so you're almost
on autopilot yeah it's literally like
this so I went home I did it and I felt
very ashamed upon it and I said to the
Lord I don't know this this needs to
stop and I was fighting this now
for I don't know four or five years
already you know being faithful falling
again but the Bible says you know the
righteous man stand up seven times yes
so then I said to the Lord Lord
something must change I don't know how
to get out of this but you need to help
me I think um there's not there was not
a reason to fell into it before but I
believe you know the Bible has this
concept of righteousness by faith which
means that the righteous Life of Christ
is given to us um in a practical way not
just to forgive our sins but also to
have the grace the power to overcome
situations like this and um I think that
my faith was weak in that sense that I
still had this pleasure in my mind what
it will do to me when I do it and I
think I still loved it too much
somehow so I was not even if I prayed
and I was sincere I said Lord take it
away from me but I think in the back of
my mind I was somehow still you know
holding to
it another situation in a few months
later this urge Came Upon me very
strongly again I said man where do where
did this come from now now it was not
exposed to something so I was in my room
sitting on my desk like right now doing
something and it came over me and I said
Lord okay I started to pray again this
time I went on my knees started to pray
and then I remembered something that I
have read in a book a powerful book with
the title Ministry of
healing and there's a
quotation um where it's talking about
that song is a
weapon so this came in my mind that
situation and the Bible says that the
angels of God surrounding around those
who you know looking for help um with
God so I was literally thinking my mind
okay if I'm sitting here right now
having this urge I know it's wrong I
understand the great controversy between
Christ and Satan from the Bible very
much um even if you listen you know to
my testimony people can hear what was
going on in my life so I understood that
concept I know there are faithful angels
and there are fallen angels to demons
and they try to urge you in that or
bring that bring you in that direction
so I said okay I kneel down now I will
pray claim the promises of
God uh not that I didn't do this before
but this time I add also that weapon of
song so I started to sing loud I mean
I'm not the best singer I must say
and uh but I know that the Angels start
to Camp around you so by doing this and
I was thinking I had this this concept
in my mind I just want to read this to
you um in Hebrews chapter
3 it's very interesting principle and
concept which came in my mind in that
moment in Hebrews chapter 3 it says in
verse 13 but exort one another daily
while it is called today lest any of you
be hardened through the deceitfulness of
sin so I was thinking sin is a deception
I got this in my mind and I hope it's
helpful for some of us um sounds a
little bit intellectual but it helped me
I was thinking okay if sin is deceiving
you I mean I had this pleasureful
feelings not yeah you cannot discuss
about this it's it's it's a wonderful
feeling um but I was think I understood
the concept that this is we've talked
about it's selfish you know it's out of
the realm of of of God's Will and this
is destroying me and relationships so I
said okay even if it is real it's there
the feelings are there but it's a
deceptive feeling it will destroy you at
the end so and then I was thinking okay
it came out of the blue so there must be
the same situation must happen that it
that will just disappear again so I
prayed I
quoted um scripture and I started to
sing and I realized I I said to myself
this time I will not get up until this
urge is gone because it came out of the
blue it must disappear again so while I
was doing this I realized after a while
that this urge became less and less and
less until a moment after a few minutes
that I was just sober this urge was just
gone then I was thinking
that's it so I can use that concept
every time um knowing that when it comes
back and it came back you know a lot of
times it came he's going to circle back
around and double down on the next one
definitely but I knew okay I took
another Stone from here and put it on
this side now I saw myself that this
pile of stone became less and less and
less and every time after that situation
I found myself again with a strong urge
and sometimes people people might not
understand how strong this is upon you
but it's really you're messing with your
brain's chemistry yeah definitely it's
so strong on you you really like a slave
um mean sexuality should be something
that we can enjoy in marriage and it
shouldn't control youh so and then every
time I came back in that situation
having this urge I'm using the same
method and then every time I came out
quicker being sober you know being in
that situation where I was not
controlled by it anymore mhm and then um
was a blessing that actually just
briefly before I met my wife first time
um and I was fighting this fight for I
don't know how many years now that God
gave me really complete victory over it
beautiful what I mean by that is I still
believe that God has given sexuality I
mean I'm now with my wife and of course
you know we have sexuality in the
marriage um but I'm not going back to to
self
abuse and I know that sexuality doesn't
control me anymore by God's grace and
power I can control it today and use it
in a way like we said to serve MH the
other person MH and be blessed by it in
the same time um but it doesn't control
me anymore so I saw this power and this
testimony having this strong urge and
god Set Me Free from that though it was
a struggle today I can say this is one
of the greatest evidences for me me for
God existence mhm that his word is true
that I want to praise him that um you
know the gospel is real and like Paul
says it's the power unto salvation just
about ready to say it's power yeah it is
power and and outside of that you can't
stop on your own no it's not possible to
be really free you know there people for
example they stop drinking alcohol like
the how you call that here the a AA AA
Alcoholics Anonymous and uh you know God
bless these people and they have their
Concepts but it's not really that you
are really set free you just stop with
it sometimes but you're still struggling
really to be free is that that when the
Temptation comes you know it doesn't
bother youm doesn't bother you any if I
go for example today in a shop and see
alcohol and I was drinking Heavenly in
the past when I see alcohol today it's
for me like wouldn't be a Temptation at
this point not at all not at all and
this is the same how I feel about
sexuality I can enjoy it I can control
it I can use it as a method of service
MH but it's not I'm I'm not enslaved to
this anymore and this is powerful and if
you experience have experience something
like this I believe today that God can
set me free from whatever it is MH this
is really beautiful that God has created
a A system that can
heal the ground you're a farmer you like
farming right even if the soil is
completely messed up you can put the
right elements back back into the soil
and rest up a beautiful soil for for
beautiful plants yes we are like that as
well you can't you can't get to the
place where you're like oh I've gone
this far and and there's no hope for me
so I'm just going to embrace it you know
I think it's even more amazing when God
takes somebody that's that chemically
addicted like what you said you you it's
driving you I mean it's literally
physically like in your body making you
go achieve that thing and God can take
that
yeah and this is this this is where I
think you know
people there's this you know overarching
thing that you know there's certain
things that God can't help you with
really there's there's things that God
actually can't help me with I think he
can help you with everything absolutely
I mean you know there's not a time where
God is saying to you I'm sorry you know
I could help you so far now I'm out of
power or whatever you know it's God
there's this concept in the Bible that
God wants us you know to come to True
maturity in in in our characters that we
reflect Christ completely I believe that
from the bottom of my heart and I
believe it's possible I see you know I'm
there there are things in my life which
are still not like were presented Christ
correctly but I know that God if I cling
to him Faithfully he will do that I
believe that beautiful yeah and there's
hope I want to say There's Hope for
everyone and if somebody is struggling
with that there is hope even if you know
find yourself in the same situation
since years being even 80 years old
there is hope talk about it maybe find
an accountability partner there's a lot
of um accountability websites that are
out there and and you can make the steps
but I think like AA and you kind of hit
on this some of those steps can help you
but if you really truly want to resolve
it you need to involve God and God will
help you through that situation yeah
beautiful Teo thank you so much for for
discussing this difficult to thank you
for your honesty and uh that's the thing
folks if you can be honest with some of
these things that we struggle in there's
no shame in coming to God and saying
look I've got myself into this problem
there's such a variety of reasons why
people get involved in in in self- abuse
and you know maybe they they were
inappropriately touched as a child or
whatever but God still can take you
wherever you're at and bring you out of
it and still give you the opportunity to
share this beautiful gift gift with your
your spouse and I believe that if you do
it the way that God intended us to
experience
pleasure you will not go you you will
you will think that the world's ways are
not even close to comparing to God's
methods so thank you guys for listening
we'd love to hear what you think about
this conversation and um keep us in your
prayers and thank you for watching LED
live God bless
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm sorry do we know each other it seems
like maybe we've met before I don't know
this is uh it's awkward though just as
much for me as it is for you I really
wish I had a conversation
starter oh hey oh what's on my shirt and
this is the story of the Three Angels
message from Revelation 14 wow that
totally worked you know if you have
trouble starting conversations like me
maybe you should try lightwear
[Music]
you
Jacob and he form you
Israel will make him a pillar in the
temple of my God and he shall go out no
more I will ride on him the name of my
God strong in the Lord and in the power
shall
strength
[Music]
m i PR alone but by every word that
proceeds from the mouth of God
[Music]